[Laughter]
[Music]
but a new day
brings new opportunities and i was ready
to make a statement
how does the saying go
[Music]
when you let any social
thought drop out of your head when you
think no one has to like me
in fact i'd prefer if they didn't i just
want what i want i am single-minded it
is an incredible feeling not something
that you can really
live in in real life for very long at
all hopefully
but it's just it's so phenomenal it's
such a good feeling
and i say imbecile a lot i say there is
an eye in imbecile
when he says there's no imt just like
that
trying to remember them offhand now
which when you've only slept like
three hours is a hard thing to do i
don't remember but i do remember that
there is this moment where that emma
says to anita that the baroness do i
need to like
no amount of what is it it's like no
amount of eyeliner is going to help you
you plain little thing or something
there's been a few incarnations of that
um i mean nothing as
extreme as that though that really is
like an entirely different person that
she's becoming
you know like a complete loss of empathy
um i've never had like a full gaining or
loss of empathy in that way
to play that extreme of a version that
i've never gone through
um and that you know that that was much
more exciting probably
than any major transformation right now
[Music]
it was so amazing well because
naughty stacy did the hair and makeup
and then jenny revenue did the costumes
were so they're so brilliant and they're
just like doing their
art on you and then you can look in the
mirror and go like i did none of this
and they've all been put on me and i
just get to
you know they do so much of your job for
you that it was like a
the greatest gift you sort of sit still
and then you are done and you're like
what happened here and guy common who
did my makeup
he was just she you need to look at his
instagram it's unbelievable um
yeah it was it it was really like
it's almost not fair it's not fair
they did that and they sort of like get
all the credit for grew up
it well i it was pretty funny to
practice it honestly there was a lot of
practicing in the shower because
it's in it's actually embarrassing to
practice in front of people
a laugh you know you can you can work on
movement
with people or you can work on the the
dialect with my dialect coach neil swain
but that
the laugh is like a very vulnerable
thing to do
in front of anybody else because if it's
wrong
you're like you don't want someone to go
like that's your cruella laugh
it's a process you know it's a process
[Music]
i think the biggest churning points have
actually come from
not utilizing it
any version of failure
in my life or um things that have gone
really wrong because i didn't
speak up for myself or speak up for what
i
needed to do i've been sort of slapped
in the face for that and i don't mean i
don't mean physically
i mean sort of like in work or
um in in relationships i've had a sort
of like
you know like really like friendships if
you don't
say what you feel and then it and
something goes amiss
you really do learn pretty quickly like
i need to speak up in moments like this
or
people can't read your mind so things
can go really off the rails if you
assume that people are going to be able
to read your mind so that is a
that's a turning point of using your
using your voice in a positive way
whether it's with you know people you
love or or especially especially at work
this year we started a company a
production company and being able to
sort of
to do that as well to produce as well as
be an actor as an actor you really are
a cog in the machine and rightfully so
you're you're part of the
that's what you're there to do you're
you're there to fulfill someone else's
vision and so
to get to produce as well and have your
voice heard in a little bit of a
different way a way in
more has been really really empowering
and exciting and
not something that i really felt
prepared to do for many many years
and there's i had a lot to learn and i
still have so much to learn but
that's been really an empowering kind of
feeling
for an actor you sort of have two
options
one is that you can try to sort of fold
into and
some people other people's ideas of you
what you can play
what you can what you look like what you
are supposed to be
or you can go okay i am gonna you have
to carve some type of path that is your
own
and just be sort of like
not for everyone you know not like like
someone that people aren't that into
like i certainly there's like probably
quite a lot of people that are like and
she's not for me no good no thank you
which i get because a lot of times i
feel that way about me as well
[Music]
i think if you're not a straight white
man you're put into a box if you're
anything other than that you get put
into boxes
i don't think it's just women you know
what's you know what's worse
is not even the boxes that i feel other
people have put me in it's the boxes
i feel i've put myself in that's
that's the harder thing to unpack for me
because i think from
a young age i thought i needed to be a
particular way and i had like
just so much anxiety and so much i was
so convinced
that i needed to do everything right and
i couldn't so i i think from a young age
i put myself into boxes from being
anxious and it really like
i think limited me for a really long
time and still does in some ways
oh anyway so that kind of those
i guess those aren't necessarily boxes
but those are personality traits that
i've held on myself so it's almost worse
than someone else doing it to you
because
at least if someone else is doing it to
you you can be like no i'm gonna break
this
but when you're doing it to yourself man
that's like a self-imprisonment it sucks